well connecting to rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in Wonder Woman 1984 released its
first trailer opening up all kinds of
mysteries for DC movie fans to chew on
why the 80s
how is Steve Trevor alive again is this
what the Mandalorian space will look
like I'm gonna quickly break down the
interesting details and Easter eggs that
you might have overlooked here I think
we've got some stuff no one else did
we're waiting in case any predictions
end up being right okay the trailer
opens on this shot of a hotel room with
Diana geared up walking across the
balcony some frame photos rest on the
table looks like a black on my wedding
photo a newspaper clipping but here's
what's most interesting to me notice the
distinct railing on the balcony outside
and the building across the way
folks this is the Watergate Hotel in
Washington DC the setting of the
infamous 1972 break-in of the DNC
headquarters that later brought down
President Nixon obviously this movie set
in 1984 that perhaps we will see a
montage of the ways diana has influenced
20th century history similar to the
forrest gump Watergate scene where the
opening montage of Zack Snyder's
Watchmen showing the alternate history
of that universe were the Watergate
burglars busted by Wonder Woman but she
lasted him up drop him on the White
House lawn and say I know this was you
dick a close-up of another photo shows
Diana on Trevor ranch probably for Steve
Trevor maybe his family ranch or maybe a
ranch he founded and named after Steve
to honors memory like those photos of
rose and Titanic horse riding to live
the life Jack wanted for her even though
she was married for decades to another
man or heavenly soulmate was her boat
thought another frame shows a newspaper
clipping VFW honors local hero showing
the world war one hero Steve Trevor then
we also see Steve's wristwatch which
remember Diana asked him about when they
met in a previous film when it was a
misdirect from his man parts it's a yeah
it's a watch you let this little thing
tell you what to do Steve gave Diana
this piece before he died later this
trailer this watch will quick tip over
with the editing suggesting his
resurrection
kind of like a gravestone toppling over
as a corpse and burst out from
underneath it let's talk about it Steve
Trevor is back and it's not really clear
how and why he's still so young maybe
there's some kind of magical wish
fulfillment from Diana's Greek god
connections or he's like a vision
projected in her mind by Maxwell Lord
were actually gonna explore this mystery
in tomorrow's episode of rogue theory be
sure to check it out diana chats with
barbara and minerva played by Kristen
Wiig Barbara is the villain the cheetah
who in the common
is an archaeologist who becomes part
human part cheetah remember diana works
in a museum dealing with antiquities
so maybe barbara is like a co-worker
knows how she works with microscope in a
lab maybe a discovery leads her to
acquiring ancient cheetah abilities
waiting to take on the character
definitely parallels Michelle Pfeiffer's
Selina Kyle Catwoman in Batman Returns
mousy bespectacled shy girl who awakens
her intersex cat the trailer embraces
the 80's theme with new orders Blue
Monday attracts synonymous with the
decade also featured in 80s throwback
movies like the wedding singer and ready
player one the title graphics is stout
at us
similar to the original Superman film
but also to the kind of vibrant title
graphics we've seen in stranger things
in thor ragnarok also consistent with
the 80s there's patriotic decor and a
mall one where half the storefronts
aren't empty
also a leg warmer aerobics class with an
old-timer not even trying to hide is
talking to find a fern on several
screens is Pedro Pascal's character
Maxwell Lord a media mogul famous for TV
infomercials the comics Lord is a
businessman who gets telepathic powers
to influence people's minds
Pascal's take seems influenced by the
rise of billionaire celebrities and
infomercials in the 80s give yourself a
good half-hour to check out Tom boo guys
the legend most of America's richest
people made their fortune in real estate
isn't it about time for you to learn how
this trailer features a large telecom
facility with a big satellite II looking
thing it might be linked to the Maxwell
Lords storyline in the DC Comics
involving brother I a satellite program
invented by that man originally to
monitor superhumans hijacked by Lord to
create an army of Oh max students
infected by a nanovirus
transforming them into cyborgs to kill
superhumans the shots of Lourdes in a
glowing chamber covering every TV screen
in sight might be combining the brother
I concept with Lourdes persuasion powers
maybe he's plotting to brainwash society
via his telecom network and to turning
on super humans like Diana projecting an
imagery in their minds studied in this
film in 1984 would be a nod to George
Orwell's 1984
a sci-fi dystopian novel preaching the
dangers of the surveillance state
perhaps there are thematic parallels
with Maxwell Lord as the big brother /
brother I face on every screen that
everyone must slavishly follow Lord can
be seen holding a crystal at his desk
also on the desk is like a bone surf or
a boat and an oil rig model maybe his
collecting of Antiquities connects him
with Barbara
using this crystal to grant her cheetah
powers here and turn her against Diana
in the mall sequence Diana fights plain
clothes armed men trying to kill her
during a kid's birthday party are you
kidding me and she uses her tiara to
take out security cameras now is she
trying to keep writing to be a secret or
has she declared war on all screens like
a mom on a family vacation I don't care
what the footage is stored in a separate
server anyway it's kind of rot your
brain Steve and Diana walk through the
streets of DC Diana those are a
reference to an outfit worn by Lynda
Carter in the water woman TV series in
the 70s we also see them fighting guards
and what books like the White House
which could be an homage to the General
Zod White House attack in Superman -
don't tell me it's an homage to X - that
was no monster Superman we also see
Diana's D flying a jet through fireworks
we might be seeing Wonder Woman's a
famous invisible jet here some
speculated that Diana could be swinging
her lasso of truth on that invisible jet
throughout the trailer footage I don't
know about that just kind of goofy
remember Diana is born from Zeus she
could probably just connect the lasso to
bolts of lightning which would be way
more awesome even if it doesn't make
sense because it's a plasma but whatever
there are shots of a desert location
with a collapsing wall perhaps they're
getting involved in the Soviet war in
Afghanistan which lasted throughout the
80s we also see firing from a navy
phalanx see Wiz suggesting that Diana
might be caught and another firefight
between warring men of man's world
before it was the British and Germans in
World War one now maybe it's the cold
war between the US and USSR getting hat
Diana sprint and DC intercuts with
herself as an Amazon girl into mascara
competing in some Olympian style games
in an arena you can see them galloping
toward that arena dome on the beach shot
but the money's shot at a trailer
reveals Diana and her awesome golden
eagle armor first shown in the Kingdom
Come comics I assume she needs fuller
armor to protect her skin from cheetahs
attacks misting her joke at the trailer
shows Steve and Diana at the Museum
passing some b-boys and Steve mistaken
the trashcan for art whereas the first
film was Steve as a straight man
explaining the world to the shadow water
Diana the sequel reverses that dynamic
now with Steve as a fish out of water
and a set photo showed him passing an
ice cream stand
suggesting we might also get a replay of
that ice cream bit from the first film
comment down below with your favorite
part of this trailer and subscribe to
new rockstars to break down to the
everything you love and be sure to check
out our new weekly QA show at the big
question with us drunkenly sciencing the
[ __ ] out of her
mysteries it's amazing follow me a TA
vos thanks for watching
[Music]